so what do you get when you roll up a
bunch of let's play videos into puff
pastry and bake at 400 degrees a beauty
pie offer height all right that joke was
terrible here let me try another
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the series
channel that thankfully remained
untouched by PewDiePie until today oh
it's like a rite of passage for his
channel those don't have to be a fist
buffing member of the bro army to have
seen the media firestorm surrounding
PewDiePie over the last week from Disney
and maker dropping him to YouTube
cancelling season 2 of scare PewDiePie
to media outlets and halt right groups
declaring him a racist and anti-semite
and a hero to all Nazi kind now before I
go any further I should mention that
this episode is going to go to some dark
places we'll be talking about things or
more accurately we'll be talking about
other people talking about things that
many people myself included find
offensive time at the point of the
episode but TLDR if you get triggered
easily or can't approach a thoughtful
rational discussion in an objective way
and are immediately going to get
offended if I say something that doesn't
align with your personal belief system
well fed this episode is not an episode
for you well actually it is the episode
for you it's probably most important for
you to watch it but if I know the
internet you'll probably have some huge
knee-jerk overreaction midway through
and completely missed the point so just
try not to do that just want a logical
discussion here you can get mad
afterwards now because I believe in
context in situations like this unlike
some people wsj let me outline the
situation for clarity even though you've
probably heard it like 15 times by now
most of the backlash can be traced to a
couple recent PewDiePie videos in one
uses the online freelancing website
Fiverr to hire two-minute India who say
they'll write anything on a sign and
dance with it so he asks them to write
death to all Jews subscribe to keemstar
on a sign and yes what they do
PewDiePie reacts thusly I am sorry I
didn't think they would actually do it
I feel partially responsible but just I
didn't think they would do his follow up
video to that one features a guy who
looks and dresses like Jesus will say
anything that he's paid to and PewDiePie
featured a video of him saying Jesus
here just wanna let y'all know that
Hitler
absolutely nothing wrong now out of any
country these are obviously horrible
sentiments but they're afraid of
PewDiePie and his defenders is that they
were supposed to be taking this joke let
me make myself perfectly clear this
issue from the outset I believe Felix
when he says that I don't think he meant
to do anyone any harm or to condone
cruelty or anything like that removing
all contact can make anything look bad
if you have enough material to work with
I mean heck if you watch this channel
regularly you know that I've talked
about satanic rituals blowing up cities
a nuclear warfare enough times to leave
myself open to one mighty incriminating
supercut I joke about it all the time on
GT live there are so many quotes out
there that will prevent me from becoming
president that little guy was getting
ballsy but now I'm sucking his ball hmm
or I suppose maybe not and let me also
be clear I have a hundred percent on
Felix's side when he talks about how
much the media has railroaded him
shortchanged him and generally been a
huge steaming pile of turd to online
personalities in fact I was making rant
videos about it defending Felix two
years ago before it became the cool
thing to do how dare you make fun of
beauty by hashtag called it well then
there's another one I just did about how
the media just outright lies all the
time so I would say my stance is pretty
well established there no those aren't
issues I'm most interested in today
today I aim to answer what
differentiates a good joke what's his
name
his name is David from a bad one and how
to successfully deliver a joke that you
expect to be offensive because here's
the thing just like PewDiePie dressing
in a soldier outfit and watching Hitler
as a commentary on the media falsely
calling him a racist that makes sense
that joke works when taken out of
context of course Wall Street Journal
but those two fiber videos that I talked
about obviously didn't resonate for many
people including some of Felix's biggest
supporters like jacksepticeye said have
been toast Ken I do not condone these
types of jokes whether they're in
context or not it honestly me and many
other people in the digital industry
that I've spoken to Jewish and otherwise
so when is a joke not a joke it's beauty
pie himself in his response video said
but I would consider myself a rookie
comedian and in case all the puns
Meem references having tipped you off
I'm not exactly setting the world on
fire with my comedy either so I look
through some past incidents of jokes
that have gone too far to see if I can
find a common thread to help creators
like PewDiePie push the envelope without
incurring the wrath of the masses it's a
film theory on the elements of comedy
and I've identified the five core
problems that make PewDiePie's situation
go horrendously wrong problem number one
it didn't play by joke rule a lot of
people coming to the defense of
PewDiePie are saying that this situation
proves that political correctness has
killed our ability to make jokes about
offensive topics I disagree you can make
jokes about anything but the way that
that joke is set up really matters so
let's consider two situations by
comedians who made jokes about one of
the most sensitive subjects possible
rape told you I give you that trigger
warning at the beginning for a reason in
the first situation comedian Daniel Tosh
was performing a stand-up act in 2012
until the few jokes about rape prompting
a woman in the audience to shout out
actually rape jokes are never funny
Tosh replied to the interruption by
saying well it sounds like she's been
raped by five guys one of the women in
the audience wrote about the incident in
a tumblr post that went viral Tosh
received the coming heat for the joke
and ultimately apologized for his
actions in the second situation louis
c.k told this joke in a stand-up special
in 2006 not condoning rape obviously you
should never rape anyone unless you have
a reason like you want totally they
won't let you which paper
option do you have granted this joke was
told a few years before Tasha's but
there was no media firestorm and in fact
a writer from Jezebel cited this joke as
one of the right ways to make a rape
joke in the aftermath of the Tosh
controversy both jokes are made
nonchalantly and are about a horrifying
subject so why does one deserve an
apology and the other deserves praise
well nothing ruins a joke faster than
analyzing it so let's do that let's
start with Louie CK Louie's joke follows
a textbook joke setup you have a simple
premise a turn on that premise and
finally a punchline the setup was the
simple declaration that you should never
rape someone something that presumably
everyone in the audience is going to
agree with the turn on that premise then
is that rape can be justified if it has
a good reason the thought that any good
reason could exist to excuse it catches
the audience by surprise this is
immediately followed by the punchline
meant to show the ridiculousness of the
rationale that's behind the race a point
that he further clarifies by the
sarcastic rhetorical question what other
option do you have the ultimate butt of
this joke are males feeling entitled to
sex it's all really clear without
explanation the way he presents his
comments follows the clear structure
that we all implicitly recognize as a
joke
Josh's joke though is a bit less clear
and to be fair to him part of it is
because it's an ad libbed response to
someone yelling at him from the audience
the statement well it sounds like she's
been raped by five guys lacks the setup
and turn that Louie's joke has and it's
hard to see it as satirizing a
particular idea instead it ends up
belittling a group of victims of one of
the worst crimes imaginable PewDiePie's
situation is much more like that of
Daniel Tosh's he meant to satirize what
people would do for five dollars but he
chose to do it by belittling a group who
suffered through one of the worst crimes
in history it also hurts because the
inclusion of Jewish people is a complete
non sequitur all of a sudden they're
awkwardly used as the butt of a joke
that never had anything to do with them
in the first place he's mixing a joke
about race and ethnicity in with
economic satire and that's just creating
a confusing mess
if pewdiepie truly wanted to satirize an
economic system in which the rich can
pay the destitute to do any number of
terrible things that they want he could
have made that sign read any number of
things include
leaving it just as subscribe to keep
star a frequent target on the channel
and a joke that everyone would have
gotten because I mean come on is it
scheme stuff but the joke failed in a
not setting up the premise clearly for
the viewer early in the video and B not
tying the conclusion back to the premise
at the end there was no so one moment to
connect the words on the sign back to
the Fiverr site making a risky joke like
that requires that all of those dots be
connected and if they are not crystal
clear and you're going to have yourself
a defended audience problem number two
its source isn't seen as a comedian
gamers fall into a weird category when
it comes to how the world sees us
feliks like all youtubers plays a role
on his channel in his case it's a role
called pewdiepie because it's YouTube
and he's doing it on a facecam in a
small intimate room talking directly to
us it's often hard to see where
PewDiePie ends and Felix begins this is
especially complicated with lots of his
videos feature him talking openly into
the camera or others feature him
flipping in and out of character it's a
very subtle line that all youtubers draw
because the performance is very much
tied to who we are and yet to some
degree it's all still an act and if it's
a subtle difference to us to outside
viewers who don't watch YouTube all the
time well and forget it they have no
clue what's going on so now compare
Felix's performance medium to that
earlier louis c.k example he's on stage
in a theater with a spotlight of a
microphone this is clearly a performance
there's an artifice to this proceeding
that signals the people I'm watching a
show where this guy is trying to
entertain me everything he says for the
next 90 minutes are all part of his act
and that distinction between performer
and person is very important when you're
trying to make jokes that push the
envelope
well comedians have been known to get
into hot water for insensitive Twitter
jokes the response can be multitudes
were for people who aren't comedian take
the case of Justine Sacco Sacco was
flying from New York to South Africa in
2013 and tweeted the joke going to
Africa hope I don't get AIDS just
kidding I'm white justine sacco wasn't a
comedian just the communications
director for an internet media company
irony for the wind it was a few people
saw and shared that tweet around the
got out of control by the time Justine's
plane landed in South Africa she was the
number one trending topic on Twitter and
would be fired from her job shortly
afterward Sacco was adamant that she was
just joking saying to me it was so
insane of a comment for anyone to make I
thought there was no way anyone could
possibly think it was literal after a
while however she started to see the
distinction that understood why it was
so easy for the internet to turn on her
because they had no reason to know that
she was joking Sacco ultimately made the
point that quote unfortunately I'm not a
character on South Park or a comedian so
I had no business commenting of the
epidemic in such a politically incorrect
manner on a public platform it's easy to
draw a parallel security PI here if the
masses don't see you as someone who is
definitely making a joke than what you
say and what you do has a good chance of
being taken quite literally problem
number three seem like it targeted the
wrong people let me talk about earlier
PewDiePie's intent let's to highlight
how ridiculous fiber is but to an
outside observer it can be seen as an
example of punching down the comedic
term for when someone with greater power
privilege makes fun of a more
marginalized person or group in joking
about taboo topics you're going to have
a much easier time hitting the
perpetrators or punching up rather than
the victims or punching down any number
of comedians and non comedians have been
criticized for punching down over the
year just last year in Jesse Watters a
correspondent for Fox News's The
O'Reilly Factor was rebuffed by the
internet for mocking residents of New
York City's Chinatown for their
responses about the presidential
election among the problematic parts of
the segment were instances in which
waters asked these people whether they
knew karate which is of course Japanese
and ask questions about the Chinese
zodiac to people who likely didn't speak
any English beyond having nothing to do
with the Chinese American sauce on the
presidential race the segment was seen
as a diss use of power by someone with
relative wealth and privilege in this
case a white American with a camera crew
trying to poke fun at the historically
marginalized minority group critics of
pewdiepies antics as the two fiber
videos can make the same argument that
the video was exploitative to the funny
guy the young Indian men who wrote down
and held up huge message in the video as
well as five or Jesus after the backlash
to PewDiePie
all of these fiber accounts
spendin and the funny guys actually had
to make a video to apologize for taking
part in the video we find out that their
knowledge of English isn't that
completed that they did actually know
what the term Jews meant but as you
watch the video something even worse
becomes clear you guys really need the
money from that fiber account they live
in a rural part of India a country that
the World Bank estimated in 2011 had
about 276 million people living on one
dollar and 25 cents or less per day the
same thing happened with HD Jesus the
good news here is that after PewDiePie
intervened bolt accounts the five are
funny guys and Jesus were reinstated but
the way he made them take part in the
joke that they didn't even realize they
were making makes this whole thing feel
a bit exploitative and it didn't help
that in the follow-up update he started
the video by saying noted podcast the
multi-millionaire that keeps complaining
about snap then proceeded to complain
about losing five hundred dollars in his
quest to help the band account I mean
it's great but I want my five hundred
dollars back problem number four the
joke itself is contradictory the end of
the first video peopie expresses shock
they made the site at all and then says
that he couldn't be held responsible
which seems a bit tone-deaf you paid
people across the world to do something
that you considered shocking and they
did it so of course you're responsible
own up to the joke he also says that
he's not proud of what the video
contained but if he really believed the
message was particularly offensive he
still had the power to not upload the
video in the first place instead he went
on and did the complete opposite he did
numerous more having Jesus say just
wanna let y'all know but Heller did
absolutely nothing wrong and again with
Tyrone it lad did nothing wrong so his
actions don't line up with what he's
saying it's easy to see how a lot of
people would construe this incident as
PewDiePie taking advantage of someone
below him in this case the five or funny
guys to say something shocking and then
hide behind the idea of hey I'm not the
one who held up the sign but it's also
contradictory within PewDiePie zone
videos in his series YouTube high school
which satirizes online video trends
PewDiePie actively condemns online
pranksters of their habit of doing awful
things and then justifying their actions
by saying it's just a prank bro
kind of would do that just for personal
abuse and gain you quote from the song
competed that episode but the fiber
situation PewDiePie was basically just
saying the same thing it's just a joke
that's what makes it okay this situation
is parallel right down to the line in
the song I got you fired just a prank
bro as that's exactly what happened the
fiber accounts and problem number five
it stops being a joke when it has
consequences outside of itself
here are some other quote unquote
punchlines that could have appeared on
that sign as much as I identify with
PewDiePie's desire to have freedom over
his message and to not be taken out of
context any one of those phrases isn't
quote just a funny meme as he claims at
the end of his video okay so don't get
the wrong idea it was a funny meme and I
didn't think it would work okay because
a meme is something that gets repeated
and imitated dabbing wands op legend 27
and although he says his actions are
normalizing hate science would disagree
calling for the death of any group of
people based on one shared trait would
be the most dangerous meme out there in
2001 the study low involvement learning
repetition and coherence and familiarity
and belief super-exciting title I know
found that repeated exposure to phrases
gets people more likely to believe them
in 2009 smart polexia and irvine
published a study that showed how news
outlets covered a story on UFO greatly
impacted weather viewers believed in the
existence of UFO another 2009 study
found similar results for science TV
news and how it affected people
scientifically and countless studies
including perceived source variability
versus familiarity testing competing
explanations for the truth effect track
saying that 110 times fast have shown
that repeated phrases are believed more
in other words repeating the phrase
hitler did nothing wrong multiple times
in multiple videos actually
psychologically reinforces the idea that
hitler did nothing wrong in your mind
that is scientific fact I can continue
citing long verbose really boring
scientific article titles but long story
short as much as it
sucks words matter Felix especially when
you're influencing an audience of 50
million so what's the solution I would
say that it's humor but humor done right
science has shown that humor is the most
effective means of reaching those whose
beliefs differ from our own if we're
able to last and we're willing to listen
George Carlin forever changed the way
societies look at taboo words with his
seven words you can't say on TV routine
the shows like Will & Grace and Modern
Family portrayed comedic gay couples in
mainstream media and educated while they
entertain when the entire western world
challenged one another to pour ice
buckets over themselves in a silly gag
prompting those same individuals to
learn about a not so sexy little-known
disease it was a game changer according
to Steven Rosenfield founder and
director of the American comedy
Institute quote there's a pattern in
stand-up comedy it starts with certain
groups or minorities immigrants blacks
women old people Jews Muslims gays Arab
Asian being the target of stereotypical
Joe in response people from the target
group will start doing stand-up comedy
themselves when the audience sees one of
these new comedians on stage talking
about themselves with a sense of humor
if they begin to recognize how
dimensional the stereotypes of group is
if they know how to make us laugh
there's a connection a cultural cross
over the original stereotype will start
breaking down making it harder to
perpetuate end quote we need people like
pewdiepie to continue pushing boundaries
tackling taboo or risque topics because
humor is a force for good the voice of
generation laughing is a force for
positive change so with any form of
comedy
sometimes the jokes just doesn't go over
well George Carlin was banned for years
because his worked with so edgy and
sometimes a joke just doesn't land I
mean I've seen plenty of amateur
stand-up comedy nights and if you want
to try not to cringe challenge all that
is Ultimate Edition and honestly that's
what happened with PewDiePie in the
fiber video why those were so offensive
to so many people while all his other
cast videos haven't been what truly
matters here is that risky humor needs
to be humor done right it needs to have
a clear and thoughtful purpose because
that when it's at its most powerful in
the words of humorous Mary her humor is
a rubber sword that allows you to make a
point without drawing blood but hey that
oh and as a funny side note dear
everyone who is attacking Disney on
Twitter for their decision to drop
by posting skills of this old Donald
Duck cartoon saying that Disney is a
hypocrite because they have anti-semitic
history well those images are from a
World War 2 era propaganda cartoon in
which Donald has a nightmare about being
in Nazi Germany it's not meant to be a
good thing in the original cartoon in
other words removing these images to
prove Disney's anti-semitic history is
doing the exact same thing that the Wall
Street Journal did a PewDiePie you've
taken it out of its context and sure
Walt had all his issues and whatever but
in this instance I just thought you'd
all appreciate the irony and hey here's
one final funny meme to leave you with
death to all the subscribe button
kill all the subscribe buttons by
clicking right there on that
horrendously offensive sign and if you
want even more reasons to hate the
mainstream media click right over here
that video will give you plenty of
fodder for your Twitter rants now if
you'll excuse me it is way past due to
end this episode thank you all so much
for sticking with me through what is
going to be a very long video but
remember it's all just a theory of film
theory and God